they're trying to get people out of this
hotel and it's like you know they
got to come with the jaws of life
if you left for what you know check out
checkouts at noon they're just banging
on doors
yeah people are waking up groggy like yo
what
they're like yo what like this staff has
those needles that the
paramedics give to heroin alex
[Laughter]
are we rolling yet okay i'm rolling
um yeah no it's bad they uh you know
the the people next door to us like they
were just i thought the cops were here
like they were just banging on the door
and then finally the door swings open
and the guy's like
he's like sleepy and you could tell you
know
and they're like you have to leave like
they're they're like they're not even
using the word check out anymore they're
like you have to leave
you have to go you can't live here
this isn't your home
yeah i mean where are you i'm in south
beach man in miami
the party here is intense and uh
you know obviously it's miami there's
some very hot people there's some very
good looking people but there are some
real
sloppy pigs i'm talking
women in the high twos
and well into the threes uh hundreds of
pounds
yeah three hundreds uh wearing bikinis
and like the sheer outfits you can see
everything
i mean it's we've gone a little far with
the body positivity
i think i mean some men like that
sure i mean sure but i mean we're just
we're going we're going oh it's crazy
but
i have a feeling these people aren't
reading vogue teen vogue magazine and
getting their uh
taking their cues from that that's a
good point maybe their maybe their
confidence is innate
you know maybe it wasn't uh they didn't
need a blog to let them know
that they were good enough and i have no
problem with people rocking out
big people but it's just there's there's
to me there are things aesthetically
that look good and things that don't
it's like
you know try to you know a little
mystery
is nice right little mystery let the
gentleman uh
discover yes let the gentleman discover
let him go on a journey of discovery i
mean they got it all out i mean
literally we're looking at fat [ __ ]
wow
like literally fat foopas
are hanging out sounds nice in brightly
colored pastel clothing
it's still [ __ ] on the beach in the
streets
it's not like that that i've seen but
it's not
that far away right from that like i can
see it gets there
people are hanging out of windows of
cars dancing
they these people understand life
much better than people that are like in
brooklyn
in a room debating like you know
uh karl marx uh
on like a you know and they pull a ratty
blanket up over themselves to go to
sleep
these people are just tits out puss out
coke in the nose dancing out of the
window of a car
if this is the end of america as we have
you know said that it is
why not go out with a literal bang yo
you wanna like
you know watch the end of the world
while you're checking your mutual fund
right what is this
well there's also this idea that like
these people like they don't
really understand uh what's going on
outside of this area right yeah
obviously they're [ __ ] each other not
kids right
right so they are like
hey i can just enjoy what i got the food
i mean the food's kind of dog food you
know
the croquetas are good you have to go to
the cuban food
yeah that's fine it's good you want a
nice cuban sandwich with the ham and
swiss melted i mean
come on it's fine it's good i don't want
to go to war with people in the comments
about cuban food
i'm sure it's really fine i've had some
great cuban food
but you know some of it is you know
it's all dig deep fried and yeah you
know
we were eating last night you know a
comic took us here last night you know
it's funny they were like you know the
audience is very white
some of the other comments you're like
your audience is pretty white i'm like
what
i'm like what am i supposed to do like
there's diversity in the audience by the
way there's get out of here
yeah right right like there's hispanics
there's blacks but like yeah there's
white people out there
and uh you know the comic was like yeah
they play a lot of white the music this
time in the club like
they play like a journey for your fans
they're white people
and i'm like yeah man i'm sorry it's
called diversity
yeah that's exactly right i'm sorry you
know i get it
i'm sorry i don't do more bits in
spanish i don't know spanish i only know
the food's
coming up you could have learned
[Music]
you know we used one of those uh
three-hour sessions of eating crawfish
yeah to learn to learn to speak espanol
i should have
but i mean if a guy like me starts
speaking spanish i immediately look
like a a republican congressman who's
apologizing for something horrible
like i don't look like i'm doing the
language you know i'm like uh
no it's the kind of thing that like you
learned to get ahead
policy is no good no bueno policia no
bueno
me you know so people assumed you had to
learn it to get a
promotion of the dea
[Laughter]
yeah i learned spanish when we were
infiltrating
you haven't been down here to miami no
i've been to
new orleans as close as i've been i've
never been to florida yet
we got to get you to florida i'd love to
go to south beach just hanging out with
the honeys
there are a lot of big guys here that
all wear white shirts and little hats i
mean this isn't yeah
i got to be honest with you there's a
life for us here
sure there's a life for us here people
assume that like this guy might be about
things because he's a big guy
yeah if you just wear a white 5x
shirt from dxl with two like black
stripes on either side
and a little hat and you smoke a cigar
people
go that guy's something yeah that's a
problem with certain fat people that
can't become a thing
right but like these people down here
like the fat
cubans are a thing and one of the guys
last night was he's like the cuban
people because we are strong fat
because we are fat but we work so our
stomachs are hard even though they're
fat i'm like that's just
like wait a minute this is a very
interesting way though
i get it but the stomach is part of turn
here
uh or get into like you know differences
of physiology
right but yeah i i know what you mean i
mean it's like like i used to say it was
it was like some owen guys there's a uh
big samoan dudes like
there's a i mean orwell wrote about this
in in uh burmese days which i'm not sure
if that's still uh
if that's acceptable but he doesn't say
anything that bad i don't think i'll go
ask the people in the hotel if we can
use burmese days for more well
i'll go i'll go knock on the doors and
ask everybody if it's okay but he
described the body of like
i guess they were you know burma which
should be what myanmar now
and if their fat was round and shapely
not
like not like porridge like englishman's
interesting yeah
well it's a hardening yeah but i don't
think so
there is something to that well someone
was explaining it to me last night i
didn't understand it because cuban fat
is hard
uh work fat like it's fat that's become
a muscle
in a weird way i don't know i mean maybe
not
but that was what was being discussed
with me last night
eating croquettes at two o'clock in the
morning uh at a laundromat
yeah where i was that's uh i was taking
a laundromat which was good and we had
croquetas and
pastolidos we had never you know i don't
think i don't think that's how you get
work fat though
no 2 a.m yeah that is not the journey of
work fat
you know i just love the idea of a
father looking at his son who's like a
chubby kid and going
the goal here is hard fat work fat
you understand i love how like in the
age of
everything's acceptable they're
delineating fat types
you're a worse kind of fat you're
disgusting fat
my stomach is hard because i work i eat
and i work and i have hard fat the fat
is like muscle
um i'm beautiful not a disgusting fat
like you son
you will never be work fat work
fat what a great name for my new
autobiography
work fat um
it's nice being out of austin texas
which we all know
we have to pretend is the uh epicenter
of the world
uh um listen it's a tax scam which i'm
glad to be a part of but
every time i say something nice about it
i feel like a guy talking about the
beaches on the cayman islands you know
like
the water have you had the food and the
guys like
who gives a [ __ ] you know no you gotta
understand it's crystal clear
the water is crystal clear that's a good
point do you think that the caymans
developed a decent culinary uh culture
because
i'm sure it's fine but i'm sure that
it's not the reason people are going
you know like i'm sure if you're gonna
be there anywhere you get a nice uh
yeah well they gotta service people yeah
when jeffrey epstein shows up to check
in on you you wanna
get him an eggs benedict you wanna get
him to benny he doesn't wanna eat
mcdonald's you don't wanna
you want just lane maxwell eating arby's
right
she's gotta eat a benny you know i mean
i get it and listen i like austin to a
degree
but it's also a dump and everything
about it
is disappointing the people of the
audiences are bad
uh from what the ones that i've
encountered and the
the city is like five or seven blocks of
like
just disgusting bars and like people
busting with guitars it's like
some heroin addict playing sweet
caroline or i mean it's horrible
with what you described to me it sounds
like williamsburg brooklyn with the
addition of country line dancing
that's exactly what it is it's
williamsburg brooklyn
uh where all the it and it just smells
like a roasting pig
like the mesquite trees make the entire
thing smell like a pulled pork sandwich
like you can't get out of it
there's no getting away from it is
barbecue let me ask you this because i
enjoy barbecue i've never had probably
i'm sure i've never had barbecue that
good you know the decent places around
here are still crap probably
but that being said is this the kind of
food that you can eat all the time and
stuff no
no no but it's like anything else
people get used to it right i mean
people just get used to the idea
of eating pounds of meat
coleslaw potato salad macaroni and
cheese baked beans uh you know a quart
of sweet tea
or more that ruins it for me yeah no
i i i've lambasted barbecue
the thing about barbecue is you know the
restaurants they serve it in
you know and i i talk about this on
stage sometimes you'll pass the place
and you'll go
is that a homeless shelter and they'll
go no that's the highest rated
restaurant in the state
i mean all of these barbecue restaurants
do look like fema tents they look like
you know the majority of them uh the
best ones the ones you really want to go
to look like it's where you would
take someone to get like you know i
don't know a poor person would get like
an abortion consultation you know
not even where they perform the abortion
but where they'd have to sit you down
and go like
here are the options and instead they
give you you know meat and pickles i
mean it's just
it's a dumpy thing eventually it's going
to get to the point where they just
throw you down on top of a trash can one
guy [ __ ] deed in the ass and the other
one's feeding you pulled pork
that's coming yeah that's on his way
that's the new experience that's the new
franklin bbq
experience which you'll pay 700 for and
you'll wait in line for three weeks
that's the other thing you wait in lines
people stand in lines
and after the pandemic forget it the
lines are coming back
i mean these lines snake around the
block it's like you're waiting for
a a ride at disney world except the ride
is brisket
it just to me i don't know i want to go
in and sit down i want to eat and i want
to leave
i don't want to eat off a garbage can
lid but i get it's a cool experience to
have a few times a year
but as a cuisine that you could do
anything with it's just not
i mean you can't take like i guess you
could take investors out for barbecue
and i'm sure these tech demons will
i'm sure these monsters will you know
like they'll be there eating ribs and
talking about you know
selling data of children's nurseries
yeah
get them get to know them when they're
young you know past the pork yeah
sure miami i don't know if anyone gets
anything done i mean it's not a city
where you can function i mean peter
thiel moved down here i know that and
he's been here a few years he's earlier
to miami
as he's monsters from club outside he's
an early adapter
adopter adopter right right early
adopter
um is that good is that so hot and humid
you're saying or is it just the party
culture
it's just a party culture it's it's hot
it's humid it's beautiful but it's also
like what are you gonna do it's very
stress-free environment like i can't see
much getting done here
you know i feel like it'd be nice like
you know early in the morning and late
at night
but something about like that blaring
sun in the middle of the day
everyone's just out partying ellie's got
the best climate the best climate is
that desert climate where it's like 75
80 during the day it's like hot you're
in the pool and then at night you got
the hoodie on nothing better
truly no better climate in the country
everything else is humid
uh i mean it's just a phenomenal climate
now obviously that comes with a lot of
problems but
if you want to talk about weather you
want to talk strictly whether
los angeles has the best weather i think
in the country
i think i might move to one of these hot
spots though and just
how can i stockpile pennies and link the
cell later
because i don't you're gonna have to
speak to someone on clubhouse the app
is rapidly degenerating and
disintegrating uh
into a real uh like literally i
every time i ask someone about clubhouse
i'm like but this guy has money right
you're like
that guy is in a youth hostel like that
person is literally homeless like
and i can't believe i was taken by this
like i'm fully admitting i was taken by
clubhouse
like i'm fully admitting i was egg on my
face
i was completely bamboozled by this app
i saw marc andreessen in one room and i
went
this is where the power players are
every single person i have met from
clubhouse in the real world or have
spoken to from clubhouse
is like a fraud on a level
of of epic proportions and not even a
fun one
like not even a a tin man uh fun
aluminum siding salesman
like it's just completely insane i mean
it's crazy
every time i've got a notification on my
phone uh since i joined that like oh
this person's joining clubhouse you want
to
like help help invite them it's always
been
people who like literally went to jail
for identity theft i used to know
like they just got out i guess
the worst people i've ever met and
they're on my phone for some reason yeah
their own clubhouse
yeah somebody's writing bad checks he's
now like
hey what's going on on clubhouse let me
start a room
it was a great idea during the pandemic
and i remember i remember i used to call
ray i'm like this is gonna be big and
he's like i don't know i was swept up in
the mania
of the idea that clubhouse was just
going to be because i had 50
000. i have like 50 000 followers so i
thought like um
and if we don't if you don't know what
we're talking about here just google it
you [ __ ]
but i had 50 000 followers and i was
like oh yeah this has got to be big
there's no way this won't be big uh just
because i got on it early
it's somewhat early not that early but
i'm like i'll be able to build
here and the whole app was just really
eric weinstein talking for 23 hours a
day
well you told this new wild west of
content and everyone's like you can say
whatever you want these rooms that
you're in
right and then like i'm in the room with
jake paul and he gets all clammed up
because i mentioned the golden triangle
i don't think he was clamped up i think
he had no idea what you were talking
about he was like
get this guy out of here which is fine i
mean i'm not expecting him to like the
golden
triangle something he participated in in
l.a and he's terrified about what's
going to come out
he had no idea what you're talking about
i've heard jake
jake paul was one of the most
intellectual people on that app though
i mean literally when he explained nfts
to david spade
spade could not even figure out like how
to get on the app he didn't know where
his phone was
and like so jake paul i was explaining
nfts and how kids are like digitally
native to david spade and it was like a
fascinating conversation
well yeah to be fair i don't i don't
know if that's the negative of david
spade i feel like the
the younger mind has become more
malleable to [ __ ] now
sure but he explained it with a silver
tongue
like he did it was beautiful why can't
you get it david we're [ __ ] these
people
but you have uh you know
lakeith stanfeld who's a fan of our show
i'm a fan of this
what i'm a fan i didn't know who he was
last time but i
realized oh i love that guy well well
i'm glad you said that
because he just moderated a clubhouse
room
where they were calling jews satanists
and parasites
and shermites so i'm glad
see sometimes you gotta wait for me to
fully articulate
what i was about to say and then he put
up on his instagram which is hilarious
he goes hey man
thinking out of the box is always going
to come with a cost
because it's always going to come with a
cost man so lakeith we feel bad for him
he's a fan of the show but he moderated
because some of these clubhouse rooms
get real wild
and then people just put them on youtube
it's not like
by the way what a way to lose your job
like it's
clubhouse is the perfect way to lose
your job oh yeah
it's it's worse than twitter it's like
well you can't even hide yourself
you can't even hide you can't even claim
context because like
it's literally a recording of you saying
something right
and so they they they're moderating
these clubhouse rooms it's just like you
wanted to go in because what
was the name of the room like you know
satanist jews or whatever because
i don't know what time is it half the
time these rooms are incriminating
you're scrolling through and you go like
tom arnold's in this room like what
it's always someone who's trying to get
something going too right you know
it's always someone who's like coming
back from the half
dead trying to crawl into this space you
know what i mean
you know what i mean it's like pete
ulrich yeah rick moranis sounds off on
cancel culture
you know freedom of expression guys
yes it's like it's like rick moranis
you know says pc culture like he
reemerges
from the from raising his children and
complaining about pc culture
um but it was it's weird and then
journalists were just hanging out
in the rooms to get people in trouble
taylor lorenz from the times famously
but there were others too
and then there were just scammers like
life coaches and and people that were
selling
i mean this makes me laugh so hard and
if you buy one of these courses on
clubhouse i just think you deserve
everything you can
but people that were
get it out people were selling like
investments
advice and business strategy
courses on clubhouse
selling like marketing
courses on clubhouse i mean think gary
zee but like all the levels down like
when he just started when he
has nobody and people are getting really
ripped off on clubhouse they were like
life coaches on clubhouse
this is a problem like everyone wants to
show in college these days and they are
awful institutions
but when you in the absence of like
actual colleges look what you get
you get this is why you have to have
accredited universities yeah
no you get a life coach on columbus you
know i'm not going to mention her name
but there was a comic
i swear to god we were carolines and she
said to me once
she goes i'm also a life coach which i
found odd
she was unsuccessful completely but
whatever then she told me that her and
her family were being evicted from their
home
and i was just wrestling with all these
ideas in my head of like
just the confidence that she has to then
give
other people advice like that's my whole
thing i'm like if you listen to this
show
enjoy it maybe some of it's interesting
or whatever
but it i'm not giving you advice ever on
anything i'm like
i'll tell you what i think you should do
but that doesn't mean you should do it
ever
that's because unless you're 21 and
healthy in which case i suggest you not
get vaccinated tim j dillon on twitter
if the media picked this up this would
be horrible i'm just trying to get
attention
right why is everyone still paying
attention to him
um you have your vaccinated fizer me too
yeah i got my second shot
you did too right yeah i was tired i was
lethargic and tired i didn't get sick or
anything
i didn't get sick either i felt weird my
stomach felt weird
okay yeah so i would eat and then my
stomach would feel
weird i don't think i got that but you
know i ate a bunch of pizza
you know just instinctively yeah that's
my body's
defense mechanism yeah just eat the
whole pizza the person giving you the
shackles now listen
you might get a little sick but here's a
good way to hold it down
go eat some pizza you want to hold this
down
you want to hold the demon down go eat
some pizza right now
i mean when you when you when you think
about the hilarity
of clubhouse now tanking and the people
that
run it supposedly it has a 4 billion
valuation
what the [ __ ] yeah look i mean
in a country where like you know doge
and good for doge but i mean like
all these things are happening like when
you go oh i actually have an
app you you might as well be microsoft
now right yeah
no it functions oh good four billion
ray are you sad sometimes i get
depressed sure
so sometimes do you want a counselor
look i would love if there was just a
way where no matter where i am and
when i am i could just talk to someone
even if it's on the computer somehow
that's a good point i mean so
that's a great point that you just made
you said no matter when i am
when i am uh so
sometimes you're sad and you go i just
don't want to leave my house but i wish
i could talk to somebody online
is that that's the vibe i'm getting from
you that'd be perfect for me
that would be perfect
exactly what i need someone that could
help you over the internet
i wouldn't care very much who it was and
how much they could help me just just
help me but eat but how much better
would it be if it was a licensed
professional
that'd be nice yeah well can i tell you
about something that i just found out
about
yeah it's called betterhelp
atlp this is a good name i like the name
so far
it's better help it's a better way to
get help it's committed to its
commitments
stroking out it's committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free
to change counselors if needed it's
affordable
more affordable than traditional
counseling and financial aid is
available
what it is is it's not a crisis line
right and it's not self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online
this is this this will be everything i
need i think i i think i can really
go to work with this and and really get
my help
you need your help i need it you can
start
communicating in under 48 hours do you
understand that
i don't i was expecting them to wait
like two or three days
but you're saying 48 hours is two days
so you were but in under 48 hours you
could have
said you said under using 148 might say
two or three days it works out
you know like who would do two days
would be less than would not be less
than 48 hours
so the logic works out because it makes
sense you can be helped
very soon is my point i need it
you need it visit their website and read
their testimonials
that are posted daily by people that
have used the service
we i'm sure of that yeah they're real
people have to be real people
how could you fake that betterhelp.comd
that's betterhlp
join over a million people who've taken
charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact
so many people have been using better
help they're recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
betterhelp.com tim d betterhelp.comd
right you remember when you fell asleep
and hit the car
uh head-on the federal agents inside
yeah yeah
and they mysteriously just they pulled a
gun on me and they
they'll get out of your car uh and then
they just drove her away
wow then the cops came too the cop i
wasn't allowed to leave the cops had to
come
but they did they just bolted did your
car insurance go up after that
skyrocketed well here's what i couldn't
i couldn't even pay
it i wasn't making that much money so i
had to just stop paying it and
i still don't have a license right now
it's terrible the reality is you didn't
have the education the education is what
matters and gabby is a great place to
see if you can get
the same insurance coverage you have now
for less money they are the one true
comparison platform with real rates
they give you they don't care that if i
heard a federal agent
they don't care about that i don't think
it matters because they're a platform
with real rates
oh and and they compare it to companies
i've always said these rates feel fake
in general a lot of them are but they
have companies like progressive
nationwide and travelers all in one
place and
so you just put your current insurance
information i guess for you it would be
none
and you get started and in just minutes
under investigation quotes for the exact
same coverage you currently have
here's the thing ray how much would you
expect a service like this to cost
comparing insurance rates how much would
you expect it to cost
a couple thousand dollars couple
thousand right yeah
you know what i would expect it to cost
a million dollars
i would expect it to cost a million
dollars to be able to compare car
insurance rates
because it's it's amazing it's real time
it's like warren buffett's stuff it's
crazy do you know how much this costs
five thousand dollars not a darn thing
it's free what
right how ray how do they make money
it's free
i don't know that's not my problem okay
the people at gabby have decided to
create a free platform where you can
compare insurance average customers how
much do you think they save
per year on average ray guess
50 bucks no they saved 961 dollars per
year on average
it's a great it's a great platform
gabby.com tim dillon that's gabi
dot com use the code t-i-m-d-i-l-o-n see
if you're getting ripped off by your
insurance provider
it matters buy you
absolutely not got in on cryptos you've
ridiculed cryptos you've stood on the
sidelines with the institutional
investors
in your hamptons home you've stood there
uh
with a lot of the large banks this is
something that has surprised many of us
you instead of embracing the crypto
revolution you didn't
really embrace uh a lot of the wall
street bat stuff you stood
with your blue bloods in newport rhode
island in greenwich connecticut in the
hamptons
now and i'm i'm asking you a question
now you you
constantly are just defending the old
guard all right
and i get it but can you speak on this
can you speak on your resistance
let's get something clear i lost blood
in wall street's best
how much did you lose 250 about 250
dollars
yeah i got out you know but i got it i
got out because you know i was like
um it's like you guys i i have hope
i'm the rare cynic who can have hope yes
you know i watch
more of a movie and i cry yeah i lose
some money on wall street yeah because
you're crying because you're being tased
you're watching it through the window of
someone else's home
and the security approach i don't have
cable yeah um
so look it's everything
looks great now and i look like a big
idiot look i don't personally care
because i'm not the guy
regardless of whether i think it's good
or not like i don't think uh
did you see the bill maher piece on it i
did see
it um his reasoning was a little uh
just old man yelling at the sun kind of
thing yes but
it wasn't totally he wasn't totally
wrong he's like ethereum
has more market cap than disney and it
has no prob you know what i mean it's
like
yeah but it's just
he's such a hateable person every time i
talk about this
i am every comment section of me and
every
i'm the big fat [ __ ] who doesn't
understand
i'm making 10 year old arguments let's
get something included the arguments
were never addressed
because they can't be addressed right uh
this is not
well you know how i'll address them
right now i'll adjust it right now
make one of your arguments against
crypto i'm gonna address it right now in
my opinion who i am now with my
ray-bans and my miami hat okay
here's one here's a new one i have yeah
other people have it so we have like
at least four cryptos that are really
like capped up right five
a ton a bunch are they all going to be
currency
how about you go [ __ ] your mother
but are they all going to be away ask me
is it a good idea to let people that are
buying houses defer
interest it's a good idea to allow
people who are buying houses hey
go [ __ ] your mother
see that's the response that stops
people like you in your tracks
because you come we're having a party
right this is the thing about a party
people are trying to ruin a party
this is a party during a high school
party
when you're fingering your friends and
if you're like me you're hugging your
friends because they won't [ __ ] you
whatever if you're in the middle of a
high school party and people are drunk
and everybody it's senior year nobody
comes up to you and goes
do you think we'll all be as close when
we're in college
and that's what you're doing you're
coming up to people at a party and going
what's tomorrow at 3 p.m gonna be like
and you're like dude
i don't know but it's [ __ ] 1am now
and it's
lit so i my argument is that [ __ ] is lit
no they're not all going to be
currencies
bitcoin is the reserve currency and all
the other currencies are going to be
little fun things that people
can enjoy and possess and find whatever
value they find
in them okay but that that's inherently
an argument against them no
i mean it's like oh it's it's a troll
though cool it's a digital troll though
we need a bitcoin movie where they give
a field of dream speech
someone needs to get up and go like you
know the town you know the scene of
tommy boy where they're talking to the
workers that have all been and they're
like in this town
this factory i remember we need a speech
where a guy's like this
is giving people a chance to believe
again people that were riding
not two months ago people that were
smashing the windows of the capitol
this is they were marching in
charlottesville this is giving them
a a new thing to talk about
it's better than that isn't it better
than wearing viking horns yes or yes
i i'm not saying bitcoins all all right
people stop
it because i know that's the [ __ ] new
york times angle that all these crypto
shits are
but it is it's anti-establishment people
and it shouldn't yeah i established
who are actually doing quite well in the
system to begin with a lot of the time
dave portnoy is a struggling farmer
so and so is elon musk so stop
stop this argument that this is
incredibly wealthy people
duping people that spend all day
looking at their computer these are good
men who are
struggling look i mean i i hear you here
here
i don't know that the american psyche
what it needs most right now is hope
i think you know i think fair point hope
is kind of the the the
antecedent more than ever to
self-reflection i think we need a little
more self-reflection a little less hope
but that being said i'm all for those
i'm doing we need a little party
we need a party and we're having a party
and i think we haven't worked hard
wait where is this hard work that we're
paying off we're like celebrating
parties never are the result of hard
work
that's a good point good parties hard
workers don't parties good parties are
actually better when the people there
haven't worked at all
the work is the party do you understand
they're putting all the work into the
party
partying is a job for people people you
know we go out this guy last night after
the show or even
catches at 2 am he goes it goes tomorrow
night you want to go out you want to get
into something what circles you guys
want to get into i'm like this guy's
married i'm sober
i'm exhausted i just did two shows there
is no partying i'm 36
what am i gonna do i don't want to stand
in a room full of people and hear their
[ __ ] anymore
i've done i'm just done i was 23.
i went to parties where they said sure
were they christmas parties at mortgage
companies yes was i drinking with people
twice my age yes
was i getting laid no was i [ __ ] you
know
living uh the life of a 45 year old
divorced man when i was 22
sure but whatever i was supposed to be
doing
it didn't happen i went to the city and
danced a few times at clubs
i get it but i'm dirty [ __ ] six
enough's enough already we gotta move
the [ __ ] on
what i'd like now is a little
cryptocurrency
uh and just some quiet
yeah i tried to see city dancing but i
ended up on the side of the building
puking
in while i was sitting like like sitting
down like and then like puking into my
lap
when was that huh when was that
yeah decades ago i mean when i was like
22 or whatever and you went to the city
and you were dancing and then you just
you ended up outside puking i partied
too hard
that's what happens yeah that's what i
want i want it all right now i can't
i can't pace myself yeah but the guy
doesn't understand he's like you guys
want to go out do you guys party i'm
like dude i can't party i'm tired
i've done two hours of comedy i could
record a podcast
uh it's tiring for me i don't is
there's something wrong with people and
they're like mid-30s heading
heading north to their late 30s who are
like using the word
party well i always assumed i was never
younger but like by the time i was like
25 i realized oh party means cocaine
i mean literally like they're not it's
like it's just
the dancing is an excuse cause you need
something to do while you're on coke
right so it's like well that actually
likes it you can buy dogecoin
yeah well that's the real sad thing is
people just you know
kind of blinds the [ __ ] uh oxy and
then just clicking the buy button on
[ __ ] nfcs and doge and like
it's it's uh you're not getting like at
least at least if you buy a [ __ ]
crazy car you can't afford
you get that make it late a few times
you gotta [ __ ] get to drive around
before you crash into a kid
right there's some fun but like there's
nothing tangible i mean i'm saying that
look let's assume you make a ton of
money later on remember that
if you live for if you live to get there
there's nothing fun in the interim
right remember when that guy hit john
gotti's kid like he was a mistake and
then he disappeared
and apparently john didn't want you know
anything to happen to him but
the guys underneath them were like oh we
can't you know
so the guy just it's funny now like to
stay to the mob now if you hit that kid
with a car they'd be like good
one defeated yeah
they wouldn't care at all it's just
interesting like that whole
that's why like that new york like when
everyone's like new york
yeah i'm like that is you're talking
about
like 30 years ago like you're more
more like they're the 70s was the last
time they really had like
yeah a solid grip because by the
eighties you had gotti just and everyone
must have known
oh this is going down yeah he's just
flashing everything
new mafia is is [ __ ] bitcoin
that's the new mafia that's the new
criminal enterprise
i'm doing the bitcoin convention down
here in miami and it makes so much sense
that it's here in miami
uh june 4th through the 6th we don't
know what we're doing yet
uh the what is it the third through the
sixth bend third to the fifth
third through the fifth the third is
what ben will knight well yeah well
night
and what is that so these are the
huddles the people who just hold no
matter what
and they have massive quantities of
bitcoin they come in on the third
for uh they're calling it a whale night
they're like they know they're being
called whales
yes they're bitcoin problems when you're
a whale you're like the whole point of a
whale is to get taken
when did this get like blurred not at a
party
uh and so they want to come in now well
elon musk is hosting us now so let's
stop with any idea
that there's any type of you know uh
you know like um you know decency left
amongst
evil tyrants there used to be some
levels
just wednesdays for the whales thursdays
for the rape victims
thursdays sunday is sexual assault night
um what do you think about elon hosting
snl
how bad will it be or will it be great
um i don't think it'll be great yeah
because like
you know look it's not when's it ever
funny sorry that's not the issue
it's just more like here's what i think
would be great
a cast breakdown like they're doing a
sketch and a.d bryant turns around
and starts crying and goes you have more
money than god and people are starving
if they had the balls to ever do that
they wouldn't be on snl i know but just
think about it for a minute like bo and
yang and eddie bryant start
crying and going it's not okay what's
happening
people are suffering like i want people
standing up
in the snl uh uh studio like audience
members standing up and screaming
people are sick they're dying
people are suffering and i hope it's
during a sketch where elon musk has like
a dumb little hat
and he's in a costume and people are
screaming and people like i lost my
[ __ ] job
i live on the street and then elon musk
is like he's got to go along with it
he's got to go along with his sketch but
then it's harder and harder to do and he
starts
looking out in the audience and he's got
this little like jester hat on or
something
i feel like he would handle that much
better than like if it didn't because
he'd have some he is good at like having
the pity response to like
we'll just get into doge that'll really
help you out like well yeah but
but i just wanted to go off the rails i
i'm just saying but
if it doesn't go up he'd be do better
because like
otherwise you're watching this guy who's
confident and he's a
shark salesman what they call it shark
fin salesman
what's the coil snake char stick oil
stingable yeah and the
shark fins he's a shark fin salesman
he sells shark fish to make soup in
china isn't that the [ __ ] thing
listen but uh you know there's just
mechanics to being funny that he didn't
have any of like he's not screwed
and so it'll it'll just be another lame
episode
unless there's something to flip out
unless there's an insurrection
and then i unless there's an
insurrection during
the live taping where people start
begging him
to give his money to the poor which i
you're telling me that's not more
entertaining
that would be yes i'm just hoping for
that
so a millionaire is going to be asking a
billionaire to give more money to the
poor that's the fun of it yes yeah
okay look the inherent
hypocrisy is not unheard of i just want
a little
lamb's blood on the door as they would
say no violence
no violence just just awkwardness
that would be fun it would be very fun
mad tv would have done that
it would have been great yeah well the
cast members at man tv would have
literally been homeless
it would have been like i'm asking you
for help
i mean i wonder what it's like you know
there's going to be all these stories i
guess that come out after the fact about
like you know what was it really like
backstage with elon
but it's like listen lauren's worth half
a billion and he's a legend deserves his
money would have
but like the idea that like what i guess
i mean i mean he's got you know okay
look at that
he stole it what'd you say everyone
deserves their money unless they stole
it so
great i mean he doesn't deserve it the
last few seasons but he's deserved sure
what i mean comedy the most powerful
force in american comedy probably ever
in terms of what he's curated that's why
it sucks so much but sure
that that being said he didn't think we
raised the level of war
right the guy's not poor no he's doing
quite well so like the idea that like
elon musk
that comes in and they're all like i
it's so where do you draw the line
it's like 500 million is that okay
but this guy does have 100 billion so i
get what you're saying but
you know some people would make that
argument about people worth 500 million
i look i mean we all acknowledge that
money is fake right which is all bitcoin
thing
like we get it it's fiat money love is
created like
by [ __ ] and people are acting like
elon musk his value went up and
therefore like
he took that like he took turnips off
your children's plate
away from them like they're like like
they would have had a sack of flour
if if the price of tesla didn't go up
right like it's
disconnected like it's all like i don't
like them i think it's a big scam i know
you know
they're good cars i'm told it's fine but
like you know i don't know i don't think
he even invented the cars but
he didn't brand himself as like he's
branded himself
as kind of like
the adolescent billionaire in a way
like he's just this impulsive uh
social media driven personality
that like is talking about going to mars
all the time and like
you know has the hot uh performer wife
who tattooed
uh alien uh things on her back and they
named their kid after a math equation or
whatever
like he's he's you know whereas bill
gates has branded himself as like i am
your father
and i will help you and i'm a public
health uh
guru and me and my wife what about hope
talk about
the lack of hope of watching billion be
like oh you can be a billionaire and
then you're
gonna be warren buffett or bill gates
right like what's the point of any of
this at least elon musk
it gets like the lottery gives you an
illusion of like oh
like you can just if you make a million
dollars you can
[ __ ] a tree if you want yeah or whatever
yeah right
right at least it gives you some it
gives you some hope the idea that it
means something
well bill gates's argument is like hey
man
i made all this money and now i i really
want control over all life on the planet
so that will motivate a certain group of
people
bill gates supposedly there's stuff
coming out now where melinda gates
warned bill about epstein's like i don't
want anyone near him and bill's like
i think he's a good guy like he
literally met him once and melinda's
like hey
i think there's some problems here and
bill's like you're always doing this
with my new friends
you know she's like bill he's got an
island there's all these young women
around he's like
you're always doing this with my friends
you know i love you but i also need
other people
to hang out with us we just can't have a
guys night it's a boys night
we can't have man club men's night i
mean it's a weird marriage because
apparently
uh like one of the deal breakers was
like look we can be married i'm not
gonna cheat on you
wink wink but i'm going to take one
vacation a year with my ex-girlfriend
where we go to a beach house and
ride dune buggies and like talk and talk
on the beach
and she was like that's cool that's yeah
well i would too with that kind of money
yeah
sure no but like it's just it's a
bizarre like why can't you just go to
vegas
and tell your wife you're at a meeting
why do you have to like it's a weird
level of like
i'm going to let you know your face i'm
really this is what i go back to
nobody sees any value anymore in lying
right
the this is a this this obsession with
truth is destroying our society
um lying is is for people you care about
so this this thing of like full
disclosure all the time and i want to be
honest i'm going to let it hang out this
is who i am
it's really destructive truly being who
you are
admitting the things you think about
getting on a a level of honesty
and sharing all your thoughts feelings
fears and insecurities with the world
is terribly destructive and it will
eventually lead to your
uh destruction i mean it's a horrible
idea you should have
secrets you should have secrets not huge
ones not epstein-level secrets but
you should have secrets and you should
choose your friends and lovers based on
the people you're willing to share
certain secrets with but you don't want
to share everything because then you're
not a mystery anymore
nobody likes someone who's not a mystery
you want someone to be a little bit of a
mystery
if you're not taking something to the
grave you lived your life wrong
that's what i mean all these
billionaires are so upsetting now
because you're constantly vomiting every
thought on twitter
you know there's no mystery to them we
don't we know everything about them
we know everything about celebrity
celebrity has been destroyed in this
country
because it's been commodified in this
weird way through social media that
we're seeing
the omelets they eat the vacations they
take and
they're there there's no value to the
mystery of like i wonder what that
person's really like
can you imagine how you know how like
all these like those nazis you went to
argentina after the war
yeah can you imagine how quickly they
would have gotten caught nowadays right
they would just yeah they'd be
tick-tocking
they'd be tick-tocking german songs in
argentina
right but the problem is the lack of
mystery and i've talked about this and
and it's with with with people that are
successful in business
athletes entertainers people don't want
to know you
that well it's why i don't do a podcast
every day it's why i don't do an
instagram story all the time i love
whitney cummings
you know what i mean i do and i'm
legally obligated to say that because
i've signed a contract
but i know i do love whitney but the
reality is whitney does instagram
stories all day every day
now yes they'll be used in a documentary
several years from now
charting her course into uh madness and
they will
never use in court and they'll be used
as evidence in court when she finally
blows uh the brains off of that
veterinarian she's dating but the point
is i'm saying
she's too exposed you're too accessible
people want less
she always tells me they want more and
i'm like they think they want more like
people tell me i want you to podcast
every day and i'm like you think you
want that you don't
you don't know what you want the artist
has to be above
the page the patreon of the arts we
recall the victim or the
the audience yeah i loved it i'm we're
saying this i'm in a miami hat and
shades
smoking cigarettes in a hotel bathroom
right do you listen to music
uh yeah i'm a fan of music i like
classical music and jazz
do you listen to podcasts not usually
i'll tell you what i these apple earpods
i have i don't like them
if i lose them they're very expensive
and they always are dying and i need to
charge them yeah no
these apple ones they are uncomfortable
they cost so much money
uh and i don't have the money so i just
don't i can't listen to my jazz
raycon they last six hours right
six out that's crazy i've been losing so
much jazz i love this
is this a real company it is it's ray
conray
it sounds like me i'm ray you get crisp
powerful beats at half the price of
other premium audio brands
raycons they look great and feel even
better they come in a range of cool
colors
with customizable yeah the apple ones
can you get them in different colors
apple
no they like everything be white very
suspicious to me
very strange i don't like that yeah
racons are black and then you can get
other colors and they're they're cool
man it's cool to have something
different
the icons are built to go wherever you
go with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing and compact charging case
i have a theory that i can't prove but
they make them all white so you
recognize what they are then people can
easily steal them and you have to buy
new ones
oh that's probably true
yeah they're always up to something over
there
but i'd rather give my money to raycon
and uh if you go to recon dot com slash
tim you're gonna get 15
off raycon.com tim 15 off and we know we
want to support the show
we know that we know that because we're
we're supported isn't a good way for
people to support the show
this would be because you get to support
the show and listen to trumpets and
and drums everything that's in jazz can
be you know in these earphones and
you're helping the show
louis armstrong duke ellington all this
great stuff can be in your ears
no one's gonna people are gonna put a
knife to your neck and take it ever
listen to eddie james
oh she's amazing my love has come along
have you ever have you ever heard it
last
yeah it's great i'm singing along with
it sings a bit last right now
[Music]
that's not bad right so i love you
you can do that raycon wireless earbuds
an incredible name raycon wireless
earbud you get them
and you're good get them and buy six or
eight pairs
because stop asking so many questions
just buy them just buy them now
we don't need your mouth yeah ears not
mouths
let your wife have the apple you take
the right one
bye raycon dot com slash tim buy
raincon.com
right yeah do you sometimes
not are you disappointed by the options
at the supermarket
yeah you know i want to make a nice
souffle but i can't figure out how to do
it so i just buy a pizza
sometimes don't you want people to
deliver fresh food to your door i just
want you know
i i want to stop feeling so unhealthy
so hello i keep eating the pizza i need
something nice and green coming to my
house
hello fresh try meals ready in 20
minutes or less
lightening prep very easy that's the
problem because i want to wait i don't
know
i'm too greedy i don't want to waste too
much time for a nice fresh meal
20 minutes or less that's great 20
minutes or less
there's no grocery store trips you can
enjoy cooking and get dinner on the
table in about 30 minutes or less
i hate the grocery store because we have
people you see when you go to the
grocery it's the worst awful depressed
people not
sanitary yeah hello freshman all the
ingredients are sourced directly from
the growers and delivered
from the farm to your front door in
under a week
contact free of course they've been
named newsweek's most trusted meal kit
company of 2021
with over 4 million households served
you can get a better value i trust
newsweek so i mean if they trust them it
works out
has newsweek ever been wrong hellofresh
is 28
cheaper than shopping at your local
grocery store and 72
cheaper than a restaurant look you don't
need math
though this sounds pretty good this is
nice i mean the reality is
if if you're into being healthy and
sourcing your food directly from the
growers
and and the showers and the farms
and all that come to your tables and the
problem with the foods now is that they
all come from monsanto
i want real cheese tim real raw milk
cheese
like i can taste like unpasteurized
that's what i want i don't want this
monsanto cheese
no the problem with all the the produce
now is it's all made by raytheon
right but if you're cooking on the back
of a scud missile
yeah we don't want that but hellofresh
offers uh all kinds of experiences
you gotta go to hellofresh.com tim
dillon 12. use the code tim dillon 12
for 12 free meals i mean that's insane
that really is insane including free
shipping 12 free meals i mean
folks this is a free lunch but you got i
got 12 of them here
12 of them it's really good to eat
things that are fresh and they're very
quick they have all the spices all
measured out for you already it's super
easy you can just cook a quick meal
and you can impress somebody impress a
your love
your girlfriend that you know your wife
doesn't know about
impress whoever because it's such a good
these younger women these days they
wanna vlog and they want me impressed by
fresh food
it's not like when you were growing up
you're a little you're the older guy
and you you just cook a lasagna they
want something fresh no they want so
you get this hello fresh yeah that's
what you can call them when they walk in
when they walk in the door you know hey
hello friends
and your little skeeves out but they're
like all right cool cool i guess you can
get me
you made here's what makes it here's
what makes it okay you go hello fresh
[ __ ] what and they go i got hello fresh
and they go oh i'm sorry i was i i was
jumping to conclusions
i thought you were referring to parts of
my body
i like to cook and i like to cook when i
know
that i get everything delivered to me in
a smart way
and it's accessible and easy and that to
me
is what all these meal kits are about if
you want a diet the big problem is going
out to eat you can't do it
the other big i have tried these other
meal kits and i i've opened the box i'm
like
what kind of [ __ ] packaged this yeah or
you want to do the smart way you go to
grocery store like i'm going to start a
diet you go to the grocery store all of
a sudden you're chugging ranch dressing
in aisle six we know who you are
so what you do is you have a disease
accept it because they give you a box of
fresh ingredients
and all the instructions and you do it
and in under 20 minutes you got a meal
right yeah yeah well you're a person tim
dillon 12 12 free
meals go to hellofresh.com slash tim
dylan 12 and use the code tim dillon 12.
you get 12 free meals
i mean it's america's number one meal
it's a great way to support your health
and this show that's what it is
you're doing both you doing both all
right goodbye
fred can you ben can you bring me a
cigarette out now and we'll see what
happens when i smoke it in the room
what is it it's only 250 dollars right
yo i was writing a car the other day
right they go it's 200 if you smoke in
the car i swear to god i went
charge that now i'm like you might want
to
just charge it now because it's i mean
i'm gonna light a cigarette up as i
drive out of the rental place
you're gonna see me smoking in the car
so get an ashtray or something ben jesus
christ these people
and i uh thank you yeah sure i'll use a
bottle of water
um that's awful i want to quit but i
also thought should i just bring an
ashtray wherever i go get a little soap
dish ben for the cigarette jesus christ
thank you get me a soap dish look at
this they know people are smoking
this is for this is for whatever it is
but i'm having a cigarette holder have
you quit yet
no i i haven't quit yet uh it just
tastes too goddamn good
i just enjoy it fat did you hear this
repeat what you just said i said have
you quit yet it just tastes too goddamn
good
it's really hard yeah i don't want to
i'm 70. what's the point do you educate
these ungrateful pigs
right you know like if you when you have
to stop doing heroin
it's like no one in my family stop
my cousin is still honored my other
person and my friend ryan who just
vandalized for ten dollars is in fort
lauderdale
he's still on it so i don't think anyone
quits heroin
some people do i didn't do didn't jimmy
uh jimi hendrix stop or something maybe
yeah that sounds like a pr campaign
we'll never get to the bottom of that
no whatever but at least like heroin at
least like you know you go
i can't if i if i do another shot of
heroin i might you know strangle a baby
or whatever you know fall asleep with my
baby there's things you do on heroin
that aren't good
but smoking a cigarette it's like yeah i
might die
you know what so i can't live to see
[ __ ] uh you know jake paul become
president
fighting fighting the goddamn the
horrors we're all gonna
witness are are unimaginable they're
unimaginable the horrors are
just to climb as hard as they're gonna
like you won't be able to leave your
house at a certain period
like that it's so hot wherever you go
now that you go how much hotter can it
get and i'm not even a [ __ ] global
warming freak but like
how much hotter can this [ __ ] get
uh i think a lot hotter i mean it's a
brontosaurus is like the heat and that's
what you know
the world used to be like yeah i mean
it'll be it'll be a buck 20 in the shade
all around the world yeah that's going
to be a prop
but dubai is preparing they're doing
everything that you would do outside
like the head people they're doing it
inside now in a climate controlled
environment
they have indoor ski resorts yeah but
like that sounds like a sustainable
thing it's like
we're going to use more fossil fuels to
you know
yes further decline yes the diminishing
return kind of thing no
that's why mosque and all these guys are
like we got a terraform and go to mars
but that seems like a fool's errand too
do you think the rich ever get off this
planet
it feels like yeah no no
look you realize like they're they're
trying to like musk has been doing this
for years and he's nowhere near where
the apollo missions were what the [ __ ]
are we doing like
like we we if we hadn't let up after
apollo and like actually
you know i know we built the space
shuttle but like we didn't do much
you know maybe but but it's gonna be
decades before we get to mars like you
know
like even more and we're getting
terraforming i mean you probably need
a hundred years or 200 years to do that
at least
yeah there's no time for it it's just a
fun pet project
because you know you know it's like you
know by the time
within 20 years i do think people will
start rioting like they're not going to
allow musk to like you know
control martial resources like this and
so like
i mean look maybe they just start
shooting crowds you know
you know the hold on wait what
i'm just saying like we we've always
said this like you know
the idea is they're gonna give us tips
whatever it is and like for now
they're content to like just play behind
the scenes
but if we did rise up well let's start
shooting into a crowd i'd like to
disperse you
i'm just saying like that's like we're
in the phase one but we're acting like
oh if we go to phase two they're gonna
stay in phase one like
they'll they don't keep pace with us
yeah it is funny to see like what will
be the next level of response from them
right i always remember because that
just being like he goes the state can
dole out an unimaginable level of
violence
it's terrifying but it's true no i mean
like these these the poor christmas
it's that guy it's just the same article
he's not wrong but it's the same article
every week for the last 25 years and
it's it's all like lord of the rings
[ __ ] fan fiction
it's just like with like names inserted
like pelosi
pelosi's on the facial mount doom looks
up shut the [ __ ] up
it's the old brimstone preacher hey why
don't you invest in doge
but you know it's my best character ever
is uh
high beast chris hedges sneakerhead
chris hedges where he believes
everything he believes but he has a
collection of 2 000 pairs of sneakers
and he goes my one shame is that i can't
stop buying sneakers
he shows up to all of these lectures and
churches
where he's like we are in the beginning
of the fifth grade extinction
but you look at his feet and he's got
like just new sneakers
like like really colorful like high
pitched sneakers on
and he just every lecture he gives he
just shows up in these sneakers
and then people start to notice it and
they're like hey man what are these
sneakers he goes it's my one weakness
it's my one failing
why chris hedges thinks that currency
will fail and also he never wears the
same pair of shoes twice
it would be hilarious we found out he
had like a compound in miami
just like a 10 million dollar compound
like the chick for black lives matter
she bought four
million dollar houses i just could be
hilarious if chris hedges owned like a
a 20 million dollar scarface estate in
miami so he hangs out with hookers who
are doing crocodyl
you know he's like the worst that'd be
great
have a little fun have a little fun
chris we know it's the end you're not
wrong but have a little fun get in a
doge
look i will love an article next week
where chris hedges goes i'm wrong
dogecoin is the future and it's just a
really
well-written intellectual case for
cryptocurrency
i mean if you think about it for a
second i'm again he's a good guy i guess
but like
when you write the same article all the
time you're just some you're a [ __ ] for
attention
right well he's not his job
that's not whatever that is is not his
job he teaches people in prisons
things he chooses well that's your job
my point is like you may just say
and you're like i want to get out of
prison and finally get a job see my kids
and
chris had just shows up and he's like we
are in the middle of the fifth grade
extinction
all life on earth is going to be going
away
and you just have this resume though
yeah
yeah guys i'm really learning how to put
together like a resume and try to market
myself
and chris is like the corporate
oligarchs has
pillaged all resources on earth
the warden comes up he goes hey can you
pep it up a little bit next time
like can you inject a little heavily
into this
you know these guys we just don't want
them to go out and reoffend it would
just be funny if they fire if they told
chris say like listen we really want to
have you here at the prison but
the last time you left uh they all just
started raping each other and beating
the [ __ ] out of each other because they
said nothing matters
and there was a riot welcome to the
fifth grade extinction [ __ ]
what if he became like like a david ike
showman
where like he walked out on an arena and
he's like
and he did exactly that he's like
welcome to the fifth grade extinction
[ __ ]
he's like he's like the corporate
oligarchs have pillaged this [ __ ]
planet
poor david ike he's like the one guy he
got displaced by q and i'm like
all these crazy can you imagine david
ike having to explain to somebody
queueing on when they're wrong
at all actually you're you've jumped the
shark
i remember when i first got into this in
oh wait like you know really got into
like conspiracy stuff
he was the guy like oh this is the crazy
one like
at that point like alex still made sense
to a certain extent you know you could
tell he's you know
whatever but you know there's logic
there's like all this stuff and 911
conspiracy
and this guy just talked about reptiles
this guy's just out there and now he's
the least crazy
it's completely inverted right david
david likes like the same one who makes
sense
but it's just so funny to me that like
david ike just i mean he's got to go on
a retirement
run like cher you know like he's good
he's got just
like i'm retiring but we're just gonna
do one more like
i guess the funniest thing ever was that
episode
where like he shows up he's in like this
big arena in the uk he's like oh you
used to play
soccer here i remember and the audience
was like
get to the lizards like he's he's waxing
poetic about his days as like a football
player
what are you doing david i was a striker
you realize everyone just wants to be
famous
yeah but like you know it's hedges it's
like it's this guy
he's all grandiose but like why do you
keep writing articles in the same
article
it's because you want to get shared on
twitter like you're the same little
dirty little animal we all are you're a
dirt dirty little animal maybe the
maybe the uh maybe the um
uh episode title here i just think he
should move to miami
i know it's all over when chris hedges
moves to miami
just moves to my would it be funny if
barcelona sports hired chris hedges
would that be amazing i think i'm
absolutely gonna maybe end up making
a clown shirt with him call your daddy's
new co-host chris hedges
he is he's not wrong like when you read
these things you don't you don't you
don't look at the article and go yeah
this guy's wrong
it's just funny that over and over again
it's just like we get it it's like
yeah yeah cato wasn't wrong either i
think i don't know those guys in rome
like
yesterday the guy who lives in the guest
house
i'm like this is an interesting
reference cato
caitlyn wasn't wrong or is it cicero i'm
thinking
those guys there's guys in rome who were
like you know uh
this is good and bad was that five or
ten ben so then why did you put up both
hands
what a horrible producer he's a horrible
producer
he's holding his hands like jesus
on the cross there's not a day i don't
regret meeting him and what he's done to
my show
and my career he's just destroyed it
completely destroyed it um yeah we met
this kid from clubhouse who's like 19
and he says he's a venture capitalist
he's like driving his father's car i
mean it's like it's the whole thing here
is
i don't understand how this like that my
whole thing when i started i've always
been going clubhouse for like
like angel investors and vcs he's like
where did you get a little some money
from like i'm like you can't be a 19
year old venture cap like it doesn't
make any sense like
they don't have any money no there is no
money there is no money
you can't be look if there might be some
logic that like well i'm a guy who goes
guess the money from the people with the
money and like
give it to you like that's not a cap
that's some kind of weird in-between
scam you're a bag man
yeah it's just bagman club after just a
bunch of bag man the best
[Laughter]
i mean he's a good kid and maybe he'll
succeed one day he's not a good case a
scumbag who's on clubhouse
telling people an investor stop
mitigating these people are dirt
there's there's a possibility don't go
hollywood on me tim there's a
possibility
well he he he keeps telling everyone
he's not gay which gives me maybe some
hope
why did you just tell people that well
that's why i'm a little hopeful
but the uh but he's too doughy he's too
doughy for me he looks like a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich oh because
you're hanging out with him yeah he's
just a good looking young man
no he's not okay it seems like in this
day and age there's a cuteness to him
but he's too pudgy
you know what it is have you ever seen
someone who you know on the inside of
them as fat
yeah and you go look in the mirror you
go
no but like you go you're squishy you're
squishy and you're going to be a big
fat pin cushion but you have a short
period of time before you're not
and that's a period of time it might be
nice to have sex with you but then
you're going to be a just
you're just going to be a doughy jew boy
and there's nothing wrong with that
but hey ma'am
it is what it is i decided to imagine
like as we're taping this you just hear
like
i'm like using a battering ram to get
people out of the hotel like get
the [ __ ] out i scream at them sometimes
like it'll be like 1 30 like you have to
check out i'm like
i'm going
it's a nice place though right hand me
my phone let's see no i mean we're
we're in we're in a whatever like the
place where they have room service yet
yeah we're in a a better place oh so
it's funny my friend where i said
address and i sent him two question
marks he never got back to me so they're
he's he's he's a drunk he's drugging my
friend's out there drugging
god love him god looks like he moved to
miami for the industry
[Music]
no he was in rehab down here and now
he's doing well
well yeah look you should we we have
wisconsin what are you doing in miami
um yeah i mean here's a reality man
at the end of the day people gotta go to
where they feel they're gonna be
they're gonna do best and my friend is
uh he's had some struggles with drug
addiction
and uh and uh and and and uh other
things like you know he's just
he's got problems and he's in fort
lauderdale right now trying to figure it
out
uncle graham good friend well he's in
rehab now
i don't know i think he's out doing
drugs now oh okay well look
i wish i was watching you and joe rogan
having a cocktail i'm like that's not
the way it should be happening
you should be sober look i wish him the
best on his journey and i hope he uh has
a
long winding road to austin
why don't you move to all it's the
greatest city it's
ever been well i was about to move to
l.a then you just [ __ ]
you like a turnip you just left
listen my house that i'm buying just got
appraised
for a hundred thousand dollars less than
i'm buying it for
because i signed the appraisal waiver i
still have to do the deal
so come on in we're all underwater i'm
all in we're getting underwater again
well you got everything
no i think the appraisal is [ __ ] and i
think that the sales are not being
recorded like
the the appraisal's not reflecting the
market the market is insanely hot
it's the hottest real estate market in
america the problem with these
appraisals is that they don't
uh necessarily like all these sales that
haven't been recorded yet aren't
aren't used as comps and it's they're
they're there's probably a two-month
three-month lag
um and or i'm getting
[ __ ] again it's either one
either one but i'm going in with a down
payment and it's a nice house and and
whatever i'm happy about it
i love the whole rationale you've built
out already like look he understands the
lag in the market yeah
right no i i'm fully aware it's a
narrative that i'm building in my own
head
i'm just hoping it's true i'm hoping
that new york and
and la are taxing people out so they're
all coming to fl to florida
and texas and austin's hot and the tech
people are so i'm hoping that
the the house and you know these things
hold their value and increase in value
that's the hope when you buy a house
the first house i bought was an
unmitigated disaster but it was
really good for the you know the stories
i tell on the show
and you know perhaps this will be as
well i just hope that it's
you know i hope that here's what i hope
because i pitched shows about the last
house i was in
i don't want to pitch any shows about
this house you know what i mean
like i don't want any horror that i feel
could be cinematic coming out of this
experience
we should you should do you should buy
your old house at some point
for what why i don't know it'd be fun
for the show
to live i don't know just to own it and
then like you know
what that it's a dude it's a good
gimmick it's a fun gimmick
and dylan buys his old house yeah that's
good
jake paul is snatching floyd
mayweather's hat and the way i compete
with that is buying the house that i
foreclosed on
i got my house back people are like who
gives a [ __ ]
fat [ __ ] get out of here who cares i got
my house back
no one cares no one cares yeah go die in
it
where can people find you at christmas
at twitter and instagram at ray kump uh
i have a
podcast called uh comp podcast comp
comes out every week
you know we have a uh follow the link in
the link will be in the
description uh you can get extra people
we can tell them about the patreon is
too the
same here the podcast patreon perfect
yeah so you know donate to that you get
extra episodes of the show
and you do it's a great show lucy
steiner lucy steiner is my co-host she's
phenomenal hilarious we have a great
famed brooklyn communist
lucy's well you know she's kidding no
but she's
not yeah totally wrong but you know but
we we have lively debate it's fun listen
i love i love a communist i can buy
dinner
there's nothing wrong with that um
raycomb show is hilarious supporting
thank you on youtube support it on
patreon
ray we're gonna try to get down we can
you come down june for a week or two and
do stuff yeah sure
okay um we'll be back in the studio uh
this friday recording next week's
episode for all you people who are like
oh [ __ ] stupid but then you also want
to see me lie and
this is the thing with these people it's
all the demands all the time we want to
see you live
but also you should be in the studio but
you're too fat but you're not as fat as
we want you to be
but you're uh using a camera angle on
yourself that makes you look less fat
that's all the instagram comments
but um why don't we
start like a [ __ ] line of clothes
called thick [ __ ]
t-h-i-c-b-i i'm not not even kidding
like dude
you started something called thick [ __ ]
like ben should google it and find out
if they have it
already but like i think brendan has
something like that that's the thick boy
who cares we'll do thick [ __ ] what
about thick [ __ ] what about t-a-t-h-i-x
like fix [ __ ]
i mean no that's crazy
but like thick [ __ ] yeah but brandon
has thick boy
yeah what about [ __ ]
no we'd be the first thick [ __ ] we'd be
the first thick [ __ ] which could be big
or like uh
um
what about like like a woman a clothing
line for plus-sized women
like queen pig bacon [ __ ]
bacon [ __ ] bacon [ __ ]
bacon [ __ ] i mean
here's the thing i know that we're doing
this as a joke but you got to realize
it would be the most successful thing
we've ever done by like a long shot
i i i want a piece of the pie here bacon
[ __ ]
just became this big merch thing it
would be much bigger than like any
hour special or podcast or any of that
like those are the guys behind bacon
[ __ ] we're just sitting at a yacht in
miami
eating baked beans there's a restaurant
in miami called bacon [ __ ] there's a
restaurant called bacon [ __ ]
smart of course there is and it's in
miami right yes it is of course there is
call it bacon bin
um all right everyone uh parting
thoughts
parting wisdom um
yeah i think clubhouse is gonna really
make a comeback and i'm excited
how fun it would be if there are live
shootings on clubhouse like you just
hear
like people start doing live shootings
on clubhouse like it's just been called
eric weinstein
it's team no it just becomes a place to
like
live stream mass shootings like mass
casualty events on clubhouse
that'll be good for the stock race like
what what about a place where it's just
after every mass casualty event
they're an instant conspiracy room on
clubhouse where people just
start talking about it with no
information
they're actors this whole thing was fake
just show them the funerals
you cry we're from clubhouse
seeing the seeing the thing that they
believed in
get totally taken over by cranks and and
scammers is one of the funniest things
in the world to me
it's just hilarious i mean there's just
no way out of the funhouse that guy
the people that have owned it have been
working in silicon valley for 20 years
they're like we finally got some
we finally figured something out and
then it's just been invaded by like
people writing bad checks
[Laughter]
in the beginning it was like elon's
coming on this that and the other thing
now it's just like you know people who
embezzled money from their husbands
[ __ ]
you know marina are now on clubhouse
trying to learn from ty lopez fundraiser
for a dead kid
what'd you say some fundraiser for a
dead kid yeah
people are just stealing their kids
cancer money or on clubhouse
well all right folks see you on
clubhouse goodbye